Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Karanlık sizce nedir?
Işığın olmaması mı?
Yoksa karamsarlık mı?
Ya da belirsizlik?
Birkaç sene önce
bana bu soruyu sormuş olsaydınız,
muhtemelen ben de
buna benzer cevaplar verirdim.
Ama artık, karanlık denince
benim aklıma tek bir şey geliyor:
bacaklarım.
Bundan tam iki buçuk sene önce,
hayatım tam bir çıkmaza girmişti.
Birçok şeyle uğraşıyordum,
ama yaptığım hiçbir şeyden
memnun olmuyordum.
Çok mutsuzdum,
çevremi de mutsuz ediyordum
ve bunca çıkmazın
ve mutsuzluğun içerisinde
kendimi iyi hissetmemi sağlayan
tek bir şey vardı:
motosiklet tutkum.
Benim için en büyük
terapi aracıydı motosikletim.
Kullananlar bilirler;
yolun ayağınızın altından
kaydığını hissetmek,
rüzgârı karşınıza almak,
anlık dahi olsa, kendinizi biraz mutlu
biraz özgür hissetmenizi sağlar.
Bir pazar günü yine uykumdan
bir iç karartısı ile uyandım.
Kendimi yine kötü hissediyordum,
kafamı dağıtacak bir şeyler
yapmaya ihtiyacım vardı.
Motosikletime atladım
ve şehirler arası yola doğru yola çıktım.
Çok güzel,
çok sıcak bir ekim günüydü;
ama kışlık montu giymiştim,
çok bunalmıştım.
Bir ara yolun kenarında durdum
ve bu selfie fotoğrafı çektim.
O an için farkına varmamıştım ama,
bu fotoğrafı çektikten iki saat sonrasında
tüm hayatım değişecekti
ve bu fotoğraf da belki de
önceki hayatımın son belgesi olacaktı.
İki saat sonra yolda ilerlerken birden
yolun ortasında
kocaman bir çukur gördüm.
Kaçma şansım yoktu,
çok geç kalmıştım.
Motosikletimle beraber çukura girdim
ve çıktığım zaman kontrolümü kaybettim.
Yere devrildim motosikletle beraber
ve sürüklendim.
Birkaç saniye sonra,
yolun ortasında
yerde sırtüstü yatıyordum.
Bir yandan da
metrelerce önümde
yere devrilmiş olan motosikletimin
dönen tekerleklerini izliyordum.
Bir yandan
"Acaba iç kanamam var mı,
ölecek miyim?" diye düşünürken,
bir yandan da bacaklarımı neden hareket
ettiremediğini anlamaya çalışıyordum.
Ambulans geldi,
beni hastaneye götürdü.
Acil serviste hatırladığım tek şey
korkunç bir acı çektiğim.
Acil servisi birbirine katıyordum.
Yanımda çaresiz şekilde
bekleyen babama yalvarıyordum.
"Baba dayanamıyorum bu acıya
artık, ne olur kurtarın beni bu acıdan.
Gerekirse öldürün,
ama lütfen dayanamıyorum artık!" diye.
Bir yandan da beynim yaşadığım şeyi
bir türlü kabullenemiyordu;
çünkü sanki vücudumun yarısı yoktu,
hiç hareket etmiyordu,
ama inkâr ediyordum bu durumu.
Diyordum ki,
"Hayır ameliyata gireceğim.
Ameliyatta doktor orada bir bası görecek,
basıyı oradan alacak.
Daha sonrasında da benim kaslarım
tekrar çalışmaya başlayacak,
yürümeye devam edeceğim," diyordum.
Bir yandan da Tanrıyla
pazarlık etmeye çalışıyordum.
"Ne olur Allah'ım, artık bir daha
hiçbir şey hakkında şikayet etmeyeceğim.
Hayatımın her anın değerini bileceğim,
ama yeter ki bana bacaklarımı geri ver."
Ertesi gün, ameliyattan çıktım.
Yoğun bakımda kendime geldiğim zaman
yapayalnızdım.
Kendime geldiğim zaman ilk yaptığım şey,
bacaklarımı
hareket ettirmeye çalışmak oldu.
Yapamadım.
Bir daha denedim, olmadı.
Bir daha, bir daha, bir daha...
Birkaç saat uğraştım,
kan ter içinde kalmıştım,
ama bacaklarım hareket etmiyordu.
İşin kötüsü,
niye hareket etmediklerini de bilmiyordum.
Çevremdeki insanlar da
bana hiçbir şey söylemiyorlardı,
sadece yüzlerinde bir hüzün ifadesi vardı.
Daha sonradan öğrendim,
kaza sırasında omurgam T5 bölgesinden
kötü şekilde kırılmıştı
ve omuriliğim zedelenmişti.
Bu yüzden felç kalmıştım.
Birçok doktora danışılmış,
doktorların ortak kanaati
yürüme ihtimalimin çok düşük olduğu.
Hatta bırakın yürümeyi,
desteksiz oturmamın dahi şükredilebilecek
bir gelişme olduğunu söylemişti.
Hastane odasında tavanı izliyordum.
Sağdan sola,
soldan sağa dönemiyordum.
Yakınlarım beni çarşafla döndürüyorlardı.
Doğrulamıyordum,
oturamıyordum.
Ayağa kalkamıyordum,
yürüyemiyordum.
Tuvalete gidemiyordum,
hiçbir şey yapamıyordum,
ama bir şeyler yapmam gerekiyordu.
Ailemden gizlice,
omurilik felcinin tedavisinin
ne olduğunu araştırmaya başladım.
Tedavisi yoktu.
Yani birkaç gün öncesinde kendimi bir
çıkmazın içerisinden kurtarmaya çalışırken
şimdi çok daha büyük bir
çıkmazın içerisine girmiştim.
O an çok çaresizdim,
çok korkuyordum
ve çaresiz kalanların aklına gelen
ilk soru benim de aklıma geldi o an:
"Neden ben?" dedim.
Sahip olduklarımın değerini bilemediğim
için mi gelmişti bu benim başıma?
Cezalandırılıyor muydum?
Hak etmiş miydim böyle bir kaderi?
Doktor yanıma geldi ertesi gün
ve bana şu açıklamayı yaptı:
"Emrah,
artık önünde uzun ve zorlu bir süreç var.
Eski hayatını geride bırakmalısın."
Bir dakika?
Nasıl eski hayatımı geride bırakmalıyım?
Eskiden yaptığım şeyleri
yapamayacak mıyım artık?
Motosiklete binemeyecek miyim?
Spora gittiğim zaman
koşu bandını kullanamayacak mıyım?
Ya da her şeyden geçtim,
artık yürüyemeyecek miyim yani?
Doktor dedi ki,
"Hayır o kadar da umutsuz olma.
Azim ve iradeni ortaya koyarak
umudunu her zaman korumalısın,
çünkü omurilik felcine uğrayıp fizik
tedavi ile ayağa kalkan insanlar da var.
O anda ihtiyacım olan tek şey buydu:
Umut.
Bana umut olacak olan hikâyelere,
bana umut olacak olan
insanlara ihtiyacım vardı.
Aradım.
Sosyal medyada, forumlarda,
internette her yerde o umudu aradım.
Hikâyeler vardı, evet;
ama sadece kızgınlık, isyan
ve acı hikâyeleri ile doluydu.
Ne yapacağımı bilmez
bir durumdaydım,
ama daha savaşmaya bile
başlamamıştım.
Yani savaşmaya başlamadan da
mağlubiyeti kabul etmeye
hiç niyetim yoktu.
John Edison'ın bir sözü var:
"Hayatınızda kazanmaya başlamadan
öncesinde,
ilk önce zihninizde
kazanmak zorundasınız," der.
O an yaptığım ilk şey,
kendime sorduğum,
ama cevaplarını hiçbir zaman
öğrenemeyeceğim o soruları sormayı
bırakmak oldu
ve kendime bir söz verdim.
Bu hastalıkla gücümün yettiği
en son noktaya kadar savaşacağım
ve ileride umut arayan insanlar olursa,
onlar benim hikâyemi öğrenecekler.
Benim hikâyemden umut alacaklardı.
Fizik Tedavi Hastanesinde dört ayım geçti.
Tuvalet fonksiyonlarım
hiçbir şekilde çalışmıyordu,
altım bezleniyordu
ve sondayla yaşıyordum.
Fizik Tedavi Hastanesindeki ilk haftamda,
fizik tedavi seasım sırasında
birden büyük tuvaletim geldi.
Bir yandan paralel barda
ayağa kalkmaya çalışırken,
bir yandan da söyleniyordum;
çünkü ne yapacağım bilmiyordum.
O anda iki ihtimalim vardı:
Ya çalışmayı bırakacaktım,
odaya gidecektim,
kimseye rezil olmayacaktım
ve ihtiyacımı görecektim;
ya da çalışmaya devam edecektim
orada, ama altıma yapacaktım.
Kalkmaya çalışıyorum,
kendi kendime söyleniyorum
çok kızmıştım bir an kafamı kaldırdım.
Eşimle göz göze geldim,
ne olduğunu anlamıştı.
Sakince tebessüm etti
ve bana aynen şu ifadeleri kullandı:
"Emrah bırak gitsin."
Bıraktım,
ama çalışmayı değil
ve o anda o şekilde
bir saat daha çalışmaya devam ettim.
Fizik Tedavi Hastanesindeki
çalışmalarım saatler sürüyordu.
Birkaç saat çalışıp daha sonrasında
odaya gidip ağlıyordum,
çünkü artık dayanacak gücüm kalmamıştı.
Kollarım vücudumu taşımıyordu.
Sırtımda, bacaklarımda
hiç geçmek bilmeyen acılarım vardı.
Karanlığa doğru tekrar gidiyordum.
O an bir şey oldu.
Volkan abi
ve eşi Nuran abla ile tanıştım.
Gerçi Volkan abiyle resmi olarak,
tam olarak tanışabildik mi emin değilim.
Kendisi üç defa
beyin anevrizması geçirmişti
ve üçüncüsünden sonra,
vücudunun bütün kaslarının
işlevini yitirmişti.
Sadece boşluğa doğru anlamsız şekilde
ve somurtarak bakıyordu Volkan abi.
Peki neden benim için
bu kadar önemliydi onunla tanışmak?
Vücudumuzdaki 600'den fazla kasta,
mesela sadece gülmek için 17 kasımızı
çalıştırdığımızı biliyor musunuz?
Ya da tek bir adımı atmak için
200 kasımızı çalıştırıyoruz.
Mesela,
lütfen herkes işaret parmağını
hareket ettirebilir mi?
Düşünsenize,
belki de hayatımız boyunca
milyonlarca kez bu hareketi yapıyoruz.
Bizim için ne kadar sıradan,
ne kadar önemsiz bir hareket değil mi?
İşte bizim için bu kadar sıradan
ve önemsiz olan bu hareket,
Volkan abi ve Nuran abla için
tek bir şey ifade ediyordu:
Umut.
Bir gün fizyoterapistimle
yine seansım sırasında çalışırken
birden yan odada haykırma,
bağırış sesleri duyduk.
Dehşete düştük,
ne olduğunu anlamadık.
Fizyoterapistim koşarak oraya gitti,
ben de tekerlekli sandalyeme transfer
ettim kendimi ve peşinden gittim.
O anda yan odada gördüğüm manzarayı
hayatım boyunca unutmayacağım.
Nuran abla Volkan abiye sarılmıştı
ve ağlıyorlardı,
ama mutluluktan ağlıyorlardı;
çünkü Volkan abinin çalışması sırasında
tek parmağı hareket etmeye başlamıştı.
O an bir şey fark ettim.
Hayatımız boyunca dayanılmaz acılar,
kötü tecrübeler yaşıyoruz;
ama önemli olan şey
başımıza neyin geldiği değil,
önemli olan şey bizim başımıza gelen
şeye nasıl tepki verdiğimizdi.
İyi ya da kötü,
ne yaşarsak yaşayalım
olaylara karşı verdiğimiz tepkiler,
bir anlamda hayat zincirinde sonraki
olayların da gelişimine katkıda bulunuyor.
Volkan abi şu anda daha iyi.
O ve Nuran abla
hiç kimsenin yaşamak istemeyecekleri
bir tecrübeye,
içlerindeki sevgi, azim ve irade ile
cevap vermeye devam ediyorlar
ve Volkan abi eski sağlığını geri kazanmak
için hâlen daha uğraşıyor.
Tek bir farkla:
Artık Volkan abi her zaman gülüyor.
Birkaç ay sonra
hastaneden taburcu oldum.
Doktorların düşük bir ihtimal dediği şey
gerçekleşmişti
ve yürüyerek taburcu olmuştum.
Gerçi dengem çok kötüydü,
düşme tehlikesi yaşıyordum
ve şu anda olduğu gibi
devamlı heyecanlandığım zaman
bacaklarım titriyordu, ama olsun.
Evime gittim,
üstüme üstüme gelen ev
artık öyle gelmiyordu bana.
Her şey çok daha güzel olacaktı
benim için.
İçimde öyle bir umut vardı.
Bir yandan evdeyken fizik tedavi
çalışmalarımı devam ettiriyordum;
bir yandan da
sosyal medyada, internette
belki birilerine küçük bir umut olur diye
kendi hikâyemi paylaşıyordum.
Bir gün çarşıya gitmeye karar verdim.
Ailem istemedi gitmemi,
çünkü daha öncesinde hastane ortamı
dışında insanların arasına karışmamıştım.
Hâlâ daha devamlı düşüyordum
ve dengem de kötüydü,
ama dedim ki,
"Korkularımın üzerine gitmem gerekiyor.
O yüzden yapacağım bunu."
Gittim.
Hayatımın eskisi kadar
kolay olmayacağını biliyordum,
ama bu kadar da zorlanacağımı
hiç tahmin etmemiştim.
Bir yandan insanların arasında
onlara çarpmadan ilerlemeye çalışıyordum,
bir yandan da kaldırımlarda takılmadan
yürümeye çalışıyordum.
Eve zor attım kendimi.
Tam bir kaos yaşamıştım o an
ve ister istemez daha sonrasında da
uzaklaştım kalabalıklardan.
İçime kapanmaya başladım.
Arkadaşlarım arıyordu.
Hadi şuraya gidelim, diyorlardı.
Mutlaka bir bahanem oluyordu,
dışarı çıkmak istemiyordum.
Bir gün doktorumla konuşurken
bana şunları dedi:
"Emrah,
normal hayatına dönmek için biliyorum
hazır hissettiğin anı bekliyorsun,
ama şunu bil:
Kendini hiçbir zaman
hazır hissetmeyeceksin.
Bir şeyler yapman gerekiyor."
Bir gün internette
bir koşu yarışması ilanı gördüm.
Omurilik felci tedavisinin araştırmalarına
fon sağlamak için yapılıyordu
ve dünyanın birçok ülkesinde,
25 farklı ülkesinde binlerce insan
aynı anda koşuyordu,
ama öyle normal bir koşu gibi
belli bir mesafesi
ya da bitiş çizgisi yoktu.
Şöyle oluyordu,
yarışmacılar koşuya başladıktan
yarım saat sonrasında
bir koşu aracı hareket etmeye başlıyordu
ve kimi yakalarsa,
o kişi için o yarış orada bitiyordu.
Yani, sonunu sadece kişinin kendi
potansiyelinin belirlediği bir yarış.
Birden beyninde şimşekler çaktı
ve aradığım şeyi bulduğumu hissettim.
E madem kalabalıkların arasında
yürümekte zorlanıyordum,
o zaman ben de koşacaktım.
Bu benim için
rüyadan bile öte bir şeydi.
Daha öncesinde bırakın koşmayı,
uzun mesafe yürüyüş dahi yapmamıştım.
Bir hesap yaptım kendi kendime
ve dedim ki,
"Emrah o koşu aracına
iki kilometreden önce yakalanmayacaksın."
Koşu günü geldi.
Başladım.
Bir yandan koşu, bir yandan
yürüyüşü bir arada götürüyordum.
Daha birkaç yüz metre geçmeden
soluk soluğa kalmıştım.
Devamlı ayağım takılıyordu.
Yanımda ben düşmeyeyim diye
bana destek olan arkadaşım
bir yandan da
beni motive etmeye çalışıyordu.
"Hadi Emrah, başaracaksın Emrah.
Az kaldı Emrah!" diye.
O anda ben hiçbir şey duymuyordum.
Sadece kafamın içerisindeki sesler vardı.
Başardın Emrah, diyordum kendi kendime.
Bir söz verdin
ve onu yerine getirmek üzeresin,
senle gurur duyuyorum.
Ne kadar mesafe yaptığımı hatırlamıyorum,
ama artık gücüm tükenmeye başlamıştı.
Birden çevremdeki insanların
bağırışlarını duydum.
"Geliyor, geliyor,
koşu aracı geliyor!" diye.
Arkama baktım,
koşu arabasını gördüm.
Yarış benim için gitmek üzereydi,
ama o an felçken
verdiğim söz aklıma geldi.
Gücümün yettiği en son noktaya kadar
mücadele edeceğim, demiştim.
Tüm enerjimi topladım
ve koşmaya başladım.
Birkaç dakika sonra
yarış benim için bitti.
Hastanede altıma yapmış bir hâlde atmaya
çalıştığım adımlardan 7 ay sonrasında,
bir koşu yarışmasına katılmıştım
ve dört kilometreden fazla mesafe yaparak
birçok sağlıklı insanı geride bırakmıştım
ve o ana kadar yaşadığım her acının,
her çıkmazın, her zorluğun
beni hayatıma anlam veren
bu çok özel ana hazırladığını anladım.
Şimdi,
en başta sorduğum soruyu
size tekrar soruyorum.
Karanlık sizce nedir?
Karanlık, yani gerçek karanlık,
ışığın olmaması demek değildir.
Gerçek karanlık,
ışığın bir daha
hiç yanmayacak olduğuna dair
içimizde bulundurduğumuz inançtır;
ama ışık,
sahip olduğumuz güzellikleri
göstermek için eninde sonunda geri gelir.
Ailem, eşim,
hastanedeki ve dışarıdaki
dostlarım ve bir koşu yarışması;
bunlar bana ışık oldular.
Şunu çok iyi biliyorum ki
benim için hayatımda en önemli şeylerden
birisi olan bacaklarımı kaybettiğimde,
o bana ışık olan şeylere
arkamı dönmüş olsaydım,
bu çok özel hikâyeler zincirini
hiçbir zaman yaşayamamış olacaktım.
İçimizdeki karanlık çok derin olabilir,
hatta tüm umudumuz yok olmuş olabilir,
ama ışık,
yani umut her zaman vardır
ve eninde sonunda kendini görünür kılar.
Unutmayalım,
kafa ve kalp her zaman ayakları izler.
Şayet hayatımızda
bir şeylerin değişmesi istiyorsak,
ilk önce eylemlerimizi
değiştirmemiz gerekiyor.
Ben buraya size ne yapacağınızı
söylemek için gelmedim.
Sadece kendi hikâyemi
paylaşmak için geldim.
Bütün hayatım boyunca
birçok çıkmaz yaşadım
ve bundan sonrasında da
yaşamaya devam edeceğim,
ama öncesinde imkânsız olarak gördüğüm
hayallerimi gerçekleştirme konusunda
içimde yaşattığım tutku,
benim yolumun
her zaman aydınlık olmasını sağladı.
Şimdi yepyeni bir hedefim var.
Son olarak
sizinle bunu paylaşacağım
ve sizin bana bu konuda
ışık olmanızı istiyorum.
Kendi vücudumun sınırlarıyla olan
bu mücadelemi sürdürmeye devam edeceğim
ve bir gün, İstanbul Boğazı'nda
Asya'dan Avrupa'ya yüzerek geçeceğim.
Zor mu?
Kesinlikle öyle,
ama imkânsız değil.
Ben inanıyorum arkadaşlar.
Siz de bana inanın.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)